ROB DODSON: Hi, everyone.
What 's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Today on Polycast,
I'm going to show you
a very important trick-- how
to inherit from native HTML
elements.
Not only will this save you a
ton of accessibility headaches,
but it's also
crucial if you want
to work with forms or tables.
So let's dive in.
So inheriting from
a native element
is really not that different
from creating a brand new tag.
You've still got the
Polymer constructor
that you're calling.
The difference is, you pass
in an extends property,
and you pass in the tag name
that you're inheriting from.
And to use your new
element in markup,
it's really straightforward.
You use the original tag
name, you get an is attribute,
and you pass in the extending
tag name that you've created.
So button is super-button.
If you want to do
this in JavaScript,
you call document.createElement,
pass in the original tag name
and the extend name tag name.
Now, creating an
element in this fashion
is known as a type
extension element.
And as I said before, they've
got a few very nice benefits.
So let's say you're
working with a table,
and you've got this
fancy-td element that you've
created inside of here.
What's going to happen is,
as the parser is working
its way down the page, it's
going to hit this thing,
and it's actually going to
hoist it outside of the table.
Because certain elements,
like Table and UL and OL,
if there are contents
inside of them
that the parser
is not expecting,
either it's not
going to render them,
or it's going to do this thing
where it hoists them out.
And that is probably not
what you're intending.
It's going to render
in sort of a weird way.
So we can fix this.
Instead of creating
a custom tag name,
we can extend the
native td element
and create a fancy-td that
way, and we're all good.
Another use case for type
extension elements is forms.
So forms normally try to
package up all the values
from all the input elements
that are inside of them.
But if you throw a guy
like this into a form,
it's going to be like, I have
no idea what this tag is.
I don't know if it has values.
I'm just going to
ignore it when I submit
my payload to the server.
So again, we can fix this by
extending the native input
element.
So input is fancy-input.
This is going to get all of
its values sent to the server.
So we're all good there.
The other cool benefit is, if
you look at the native input
element, and you press the
Tab key on your keyboard,
normally what you'll see is
a focus ring go around it.
Now, this focus state is
very crucial for users
of assistive technologies.
There are a lot of folks out
there who cannot use a mouse
to interact with the screen.
They rely on keyboard
navigation to get around.
And for them, these focus states
are very, very, very important.
If you're extending the native
input element with a type
extension element, you're going
to get this focus behavior
for free.
Otherwise, if you just
created your own tag,
then you need to add
your own tab index.
You need to add your own rules.
You need to add your
own ARIA attributes.
There's a lot more
accessibility work
that you have to do when you're
not extending native elements,
because then you kind
of just get it for free.
So let's take a stab at
implementing our own type
extension element, and
that will really highlight
some of these benefits.
So to start off,
what I'm going to do
is create a Bower JSON file.
I've got an element that I'm
creating called gh-button.
It's going to look
like the buttons
that you see on
the GitHub website.
I'm depending on Polymer,
and I'm depending
on the 0.8 release here.
Over in my terminal, I'm
going to run Bower install
to pull down that dependency.
Because Polymer implicitly
depends on Web Components JS,
I'm going to get that for free
as well, which is really nice.
And the last thing
I'm going to do
is run the polyserve command.
Now polyserve, if you recall
from our last episode,
is a little server which allows
us to write our elements using
canonical path URLs.
If you have absolutely
no idea what
I'm talking about right now, you
can follow this link right here
to catch the previous episode.
And that will explain everything
that we're doing here.
Now, over in my
gh-button. htme file,
I'm going to start by
importing Polymer HTML.
And I'm going to use
the canonical path
style to do that.
Then I'm going to have a dom
module with an ID of gh-button.
And inside I'll throw in a
template and a content element.
The last thing on my script,
I will call the Polymer
constructor, pass in gh-button.
And I'm going to pass
in extends button.
So we've now created a
type extension element
of the native button tag.
Now over in my demo HTML file,
I'm going to start by importing
webcomponents-lite.js.
Then I'm going to include an
import for gh-button.html.
Lastly, down in
my body, I'm going
to use the button element.
I'm going to say
it is a gh-button.
And then I'll just throw some
Hello World text inside of it.
Now, if go over to my
browser to preview this,
I'm going to get this little
button element up here
in the corner.
You see that when I click on
it, I get the behavior I expect.
If I tab to it, I get
focus rings around it.
Most importantly, when I
flip on my screen reader,
I can actually
navigate down to it.
And you'll see that
the screen reader
is going to read the
content of the button.
And it's going to announce
that it is a button.
It's actually announcing
this implicit role here.
Now, that is very, very useful.
So the last thing I'm going
to do to spice this button up
is I'm going to drop
in a style element.
And I've got a bunch of CSS
that I've included here.
I've just taken this
from GitHub's CSS file.
So you don't have to worry about
what all these selectors are.
One thing to note is that
I'm using the host selector
to style the element itself.
And I've also gone
in here, and using
GitHub CSS, specified
focus states, hover states,
active states.
You can see how you can apply
these sort of pseudo-states
to your elements.
It's very important that you
do this for accessibility.
Now, hopping back into Chrome,
when I refresh the page,
you'll see that I've got a
way nicer-looking button.
I click on it.
I get the same
behavior as before.
I can hit Tab to put a
focus ring around it.
And most importantly, I can
flip on my screen reader
and navigate to this button.
I'll see the text
content gets read aloud,
and I still get that awesome
implicit button state.
Now, the obvious question
is, when should I
use a Type Extension Element?
And when should I
create a Custom Tag?
My rule of thumb is to try to
extend from a native element,
whenever possible,
especially if accessibility
is playing a role in things.
So if I'm building a
control or a button,
something that
might require focus,
I'm going to try to extend
from a native element,
if that's possible.
That's it for today.
Be sure to subscribe,
and stick around
for this week's
featured question.
As always, thank you
so much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.
All right, Q&A time,
folks-- Edward Wieczorek
and Justin Merz ask,
are there any plans
to support ES6
Modules in Polymer?
Which is a great question, guys.
Currently, the plan is to
support ES6 Modules when
they ship in the browsers.
Right now, if you want
to use ES6 Modules,
you've got to use some kind
of build step or a library
like that.
We want to avoid having
to force people to use a
build step just to use Polymer.
So the plan at the
moment is, once
that stuff ships in the
browsers, we absolutely 100%
want to support it.
Thank you so much
for the question.
I'm going to have my minions
contact you guys on G+.
And if you out there want to
get some swag of your own,
leave us a question
down in the comments.
Maybe we'll feature you
on a future episode.
Again, thank you so
much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.